when I was selling weight loss
memberships way back in the day you know
a lady would come sit down and say you
know um I haven't worked out in 7 years
and I I know I need to be going to the
gym and I would say that's amazing they
would just be shocked what do you mean
i' be like you're so consistent so you
already have the tra of consistency I
was like we just have to flip it and
they were like never thought about it
like that for me I just wanted this
person to believe they could do it and
so I think to the same degree it's like
well if every day you didn't make 100
reach outs or you didn't make the piece
of content that you wanted to but up
until that point you've always like been
able to like make a couple coffee sit
down at the computer rather than playing
video games it's counting the wins
sometimes of of losses that didn't
happen